and he's also manages to write all these
incredible stories which is also we're
going to talk about this morning it's a
new article out that reveals how
Facebook navigated one of its most
tumultuous periods Wired's cover story
for May 15 months of fresh hell inside
Facebook includes interviews with 65
current and former employees of the
social media giant they discussed
controversies involving the misuse of
personal data and the design of the
newsfeed the article also explains why
instagrams co-founders left the company
six years after Facebook acquired the
site Wired's editor-in-chief and CBS
News contributor Nick Thompson co-wrote
the story and he's here after running
the Boston Marathon Nick thank you so
much so what were these last 15 months
of fresh hell like for Facebook
they were chaotic they were crazy they
were intense it was a period where
Facebook lost the public's trust they
lost the media's trust and a whole bunch
of things that they had done in the past
came back to haunt them so it was a very
difficult period for them describe what
was at the heart of this essentially
internal conflict about how to address
what was a public relations disaster
based on some problems within Facebook
yes exactly so what happened with
Facebook is they prioritized growth over
all other values for most of their
existence that meant there are a bunch
of bad deals there is a bunch of data
leakage there was a bunch of stuff that
came back to hit them as the public's
trust of technology companies changed at
the same time they have a bunch of
contradictory problems that are almost
impossible to solve they need to
increase privacy they need to increase
safety they need to clean up newsfeed
and some of these things conflict when
you increase privacy you make it harder
to clean up news feeds so they were
totally struggling with that at the
heart of this is Cambridge analytic Oh
remind everybody would happen there
Cambridge analytic is the shady British
consulting firm that works a little bit
with the Donald Trump campaign and a
story blows up last March or April
saying that data from Facebook had ended
up in their hands and had may have
helped influence the election and people
go crazy and are furious at Facebook
Nick can you put into two baskets or
maybe there are more the problems at
Facebook one is bad decisions made when
faced with challenges the other is they
just happen to be this behemoth that is
going through the changes in the news
cycle in the way we take information
it may not be their fault it's just they
are the ones who are the one we all know
what is it possible to distinguish the
mistakes that way yeah I mean so part of
the problem is that they are a new
communications platform and every new
communications platform has all kinds of
masses problems and when they started
they weren't prepared to handle that
they didn't know how to handle fake news
they didn't know how to handle
misinformation they didn't understand
the ecosystem they were building they
just weren't set up at all for that so
suddenly all those problems are visited
upon them meanwhile they've got all
these issues with privacy manipulation
the weaponization of the platform
they're not set up to deal with that at
all and then when crises hit they handle
them the wrong way so they have an
impossible platform huge problems and
crises that they're not handling right
tough year yeah very tough year I was
very fascinated about the backstory of
Instagram yes I love all things
Instagram and it was kind of a shocker
ooh when Kevin Systrom and Mike Krieger
left and you take us behind the scenes
about that decision what happened yes
that's one of the biggest scoops in the
stories you know we talked to 65 people
there's a lot of new information in this
piece you know Fred and I read Vogel see
my career I spent a lot of time on this
what happened with Instagram is that
there was a little bit of tension
perhaps jealousy between Facebook senior
management and Instagram senior manager
jealousy and it looks like Instagram
well the data showed that Instagram is
growing faster than core Facebook the
blue app and it looks like it may have
in fact been cannibalizing the blue apps
users because they were leaving for
Instagram and so tensions start to mount
between the two there's some policy
changes that Instagram doesn't really
like and then in July and August of 2018
Mark Zuckerberg meets with Kevin Systrom
one of the founders of Instagram and
says well they're all these ways that
Facebook supports Instagram who are
gonna do this anymore
and then system posts a message about
that inside of Instagram saying well you
know Zuckerberg has said that all these
supports for Instagram you know sort of
link backs on Facebook driving people in
scream that collapse are going away that
causes problem that causes huge problems
system goes away at paternity leave he
comes back and then he in his
co-founders say we're done and in some
ways someone overheard the conversation
system was saying I feel like mark is
treating me the way that Trump is
treating Jeff Sessions making life
miserable so he leaves because he knows
he politically can't fire him how do you
describe the culture of Facebook today
yeah I said here today they are working
hard to solve their problems they've
acknowledged their mistake they've
acknowledged the mistakes they know
they're under siege they are hiring tens
of thousands of people to try to clean
with the platform they are shifting
policies they are thinking and yet keep
scandals keep popping up every day
there's something new and it's often as
we say it's like an unexploded landmine
that was planted 10 years ago that blows
up on them well it certainly is a well
researched article I'm fascinated by how
you got people to talk to you well we
went to them and we said we're gonna do
a tough story we're gonna do an in-depth
story but we're gonna check every fact
with you and we're gonna do our damndest
make sure everything is right so we
called and we worked for weeks with
Facebook saying this is all that we've
learned and they can say that's not true
and we deal with it or they say that is
true and there we go they certainly
engage with you thank you Nick Thompson
no and Congrats no false news and wired
reporting about the fake news that being
spread on Facebook absolutely Thank You
Nick